- I fuck with your music
for real, for real.
- Thank you man, I fuck
with your everything.
(laughs)
♪ Figures ♪
♪ I gave you ride or die
and you gave me games. ♪
♪ You don't gotta tell me
'bout your body count. ♪
Yeah man.
Thank you, thank you for everything.
- I really, I really think you got a shot,
like for real.
- Thank you.
- I really do.
It's like, it's funny.
Like as we been doing the music thing,
the combination of Mike and I, Mike can,
actually, it's actually unfair,
I think Mike really know
how to like, pick it,
but there's something funny
about the way I hear music
that like I just genuinely
understand the masses.
I just really think you
have the kind of sound
that can like, really go.
How can we help you?
- First of all, thank you for
including me in the playlist,
and thank you for Twitter
'cause that's been like,
help already.
Anything that's organic
I feel like hits home.
- Hundred percent, my fans know,
my audience is really
cool 'cause they know
I'm not like,
I don't know you guys, you're
not doing anything for me.
If I'm saying it, like I mean it.
You know what I mean?
He sends me stuff and I'm
like, nah, you know like.
- Thank you.
No, honestly, like,
I've probably spent the first 10 minutes
of this conversation saying thank you.
- It makes me happy, like,
it's super fun and
honestly it's no different
than like, all the startups.
There's an amazing high
I get from being on.
Like everybody likes it,
everybody loves discovering
that bands, and then they...
I think most people get mad
at their favorite indie band
when they go mainstream.
Like you know people
get: yeah you sold out!
I'm the other way.
Just like dreaming of a day in six years
when you walk in here and
everyone's freaking out.
I think that's cool.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Bananas.
From where you're sitting
and the way you see it,
'cause I don't know how
much, how much you feel
that I know of, Instagram
and Twitter and stuff,
where do you think that we
could increase our presence
or we're lacking or like,
where does the person--
- I think the number one...
I think Boyd brought it up but,
the number one thing I would
do of where you're at right now
is do collaboration songs
with people outside your demo.
- Good, OK dope.
- Like tomorrow, I would do a collab song
with a country star, tomorrow.
Tomorrow.
Tomorrow I would get a Latin trap-
- (Indistinguishable)
- Uh-huh. Tomorrow, tomorrow I would get a
Latin trap person to sing
the hook of a song your-
tomorrow. Now, there's
one big little asterisks.
You've gotta fuck with it.
You've gotta believe in it, got it?
Like, if you're like this is whack-
- It's just authentic.
- Correct. But it you're like,
you know what I would do?
I would fucking make you, if I was them,
if I was part of the team,
I'd make you listen to
so much random shit.
Because then you'd be like
yo, this fucking African
shit is rad as fuck.
They be like cool.
African shit. Come back and be like
yo, you gotta do this with this person
from fucking Ghana, you
see where I'm going?
I think people grossly
underestimate the collaboration
to ex- I don't think
people understand how much
Taylor Swift's song with Kendrick Lamar
mattered to Kendrick Lamar's career.
- No. That's-
- But I don't think people really,
I think people think it
would have happened anyway,
and I don't.
And you know what's crazy about hip hop?
Hip hop itself, the whole fucking genre
took the next step because
the Arrowsmith - Run DMC
collab.
The whole genre was not
built, because it was
authentically amazing, but it took,
there's nobody who's old like me,
especially people that game, ask them.
It changed everything.
I think it's what I would do,
especially this early in your
career, if it's authentic,
I would do songs with other people that
give you the upside of the awareness,
where it's a trade of fan base.
So I think you're ridiculously talented,
so I think that somebody
who's like a huge pop star
who's fading, or a mid-size
country star who's stuck,
they'll get the benefit of
something that's amazing talent,
you'll get the benefit of they
have a much bigger audience.
It's just a fair trade.
I'd make a fair trade.
- Mm-hmm.
- And I would probably
not put it in a project-
like, I'd probably just do it as one-offs.
I think a great way to build
your music career right now
is you do mixed tapes,
or like projects that are
just kind of creative
and kind of strategic,
you do albums for albums,
and then you do one-off songs
that are collaborations
that are strategic and fun
and different, a little
curve balls for the audience.
Like you doing a song with Backstreet Boys
is exactly right to me.
I'm being serious, you know what I mean?
Something that's like
fucking like so off kilter
to the mission, I think
musicians have unbelievable
permission to do shit if it's the truth.
- If it's real.
- A hundred percent.
- Yeah. You can't negate,
you can't negate authentic.
- Well and you were like oh
my God, I love Nelly Furtado
because when you were a kid
that song with Timberland
was so popping and you loved it so much,
she's not killing the world right now,
but she's a real talent.
Like, just DM-ing her and be like yo,
- We tried.
- You know? What?
- We tried, we tried.
- With her?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's amazing.
- And I get it, but I get like that thing.
- And you know what
else? You know what else?
There's people I've
replied to today that have
DM'd me 46 times, and today was the day.
So trying comes in all
shapes and sizes, too.
- Hell yeah, hell yeah.
- Duet with Nelly. Love song
with Nelly or something.
- Both Nellys.
- Oh yeah.
- It's true what you say,
and that's what I had-
- The other thing I would
say is strike immediately
if you see anybody that
you fuck with like that,
like or comment on social, strike hard.
Like there's always like a moment, right?
Let's say it's whoever, right?
Bless you. LL- bless you.
LL Cool J, right? Like
if he likes a photo,
you guys are like, like,
one of the things that I,
the thing I always regret is
not striking when it's hot
because I'm so busy right now.
I'm 18 months in to Metro
Booming and Kevin Hart
fucking with me on Instagram,
Kevin Hart liked today,
and I still haven't really
sat down and break bread.
With the Rock, I fucking
figured it out and got it done,
but like sometimes you
just like six years later
you still haven't connected.
Kelly Roland, still.
- How did it go with the Rock?
- I don't reach out to anybody.
Even though I give that
advice, now I'm in a place
where, because I'm doing
it a little bit different,
if I was doing music I would.
And if I was like, if I was making content
not documenting content, I would.
But man, I'm telling you
now, the minute you see
somebody a producer or an
artist that you fuck with
like or engage on Twitter, you ju-
get on a fucking plane
and be like in fucking
you know like Masterpiece
Studio in fucking Louisiana.
- Thank you.
- Got it?
Because right now is the time to grind.
Right now is the time to be
like not fancy about nothing.
Be like holy shit, we love Big Crip,
he just liked us, DM, you hit it up,
you hit up Boyd or
whoever the fuck you know,
I don't give a fuck, get
on the phone with Crip
and you're like yo, we
should do something.
That's what everybody does.
Yo, we should do something,
yeah, yeah, yeah,
and then nine months in nothing happens.
When you're like we should do something
and he's like yeah, get
the fuck on a fucking
cheap red eye, 88 bucks
and be fucking, go.
Like if somebody cool and fucking big
gives you love, strike, you know
the biggest thing that I've been playing
with like an econ, Crip, like a lot of the
people I've been sitting down I'm like
look you're an artist,
I'm not going to tell you
what the fuck to do.
I'm even like scared to do it,
but I'd be lying if I didn't say like
if you've got- if you've got music in you
all of it should come out.
Do you know how many
fucking songs we would have
from fucking Michael
Jackson, Biggie, and Prince,
and fucking the Four Tops if they had the
technology we have today?
- (Indistinguishable)
- Can you imagine?
- What do you think about
dropping two albums at once
for an artist that's at my level?
- Yep.
- You don't think that it,
you don't think that it-
- I'm gonna tell you
something controversial.
I don't think there's enough music.
You gotta give yourself
every chance to do it.
Do you know how many
people could have been the
biggest artist in the
world but weren't because
they didn't get the right at bats?
- Yeah.
- Do you know how many people,
do you know how many artists right now
could be John Legend, but
they took the one song
that was the song off the album?
That's real life. I'm
telling you that right now.
So you, you,
there's a lot of ways to do it.
You know, now you guys
have so much luxury.
It can be an album, it can be a project,
there's all these different
names for this shit.
It's all the same shit.
You can do a single, on-off,
you can do a whole thing
like called like,
- Fuck it, let's drop this
all tomorrow. Fuck it.
- But honestly, you have to understand,
I really believe that.
This is what I believe,
like if you and I, we
were brother and sister
and we're like fucking ghetto'd out,
didn't know anybody, didn't
have all these good people
around us, I'd be like listen to me sis,
let's just put out a song every day
with our 87 followers on Instagram,
only just, the people get it.
- The Russ mentality. Russ did that.
- I believe it now. So I fuck
with Russ, I think it's right.
I believe in it.
And here's why,
wherever Russ ends up is going to be
predicated on his talent,
but first you gotta get the at bat.
- You gotta get what?
- The at bat, you gotta get the chance.
People like don't get it.
And also how good are you?
For Russ, as I keep listening,
he's going to have to
evolve his sound, right?
Because a lot of it sounds similar, right?
I had to go through this.
I don't think Russ is done,
I think Russ is going to
have to evolve, I did.
I can sound similar,
right? For three months,
a year, even 18 months,
and then shit will change.
You're going to win if you're good enough,
cuz winners win in the end,
but you can't not give yourself
the most chances to win.
That's what I believe.
And so if you start a whole, like,
it depends on which music's
sitting in your soul,
and how much you have.
I thought so. Straight up.
I thought so. So honestly,
I think you need to do
something called like soulful
Saturday and just drop
a fucking 52 songs, if
you got it like that.
(Jess laughs)
I mean it.
Because where you're at right now,
by the 13th one, it's building momentum,
and it just might be the one that you drop
on September 6th, and away you go.
And I, like
there's nothing to trump the internet.
- It's interesting what you're saying
because we're all in the
same mindset, as well, too,
just once on the way,
getting there, and just
if this one song doesn't
work you keep going
and you keep going.
One question I have because
there's so many artists
that we're around and we feel like
okay, they've got four million followers,
five million followers on
social media and all this stuff,
but they're not really a presence.
And I heard this from
Troy Carter from Spotify
where he said, he's like
record labels and artists
think that they've broke,
but I bet you if I put that
same artist in a high school
beside the kids from Stranger Things,
nobody's going to know
who the fuck that artist
is and everybody's going to go
to the kids from Stranger Things.
So my question is how do
we get an artist like Jess
to become the Stranger Things kids?
- By putting out more songs,
more content, more stuff,
more, more, more, more, more.
- Same things.
- If PnB Rock walked in here right now,
most people wouldn't know him.
My grip, man.
- Reality.
It's just as simple as more,
I mean you're one song away.
Logic's song could have
been the phone number
song on the album, it
could have been at song
they put on one-off.
It just works that way.
Like Lil Baby's project right now,
is that an album or is that a mix tape?
- Who?
- Doesn't even matter. Lil Baby.
- Lil Baby, you know who that is?
From Atlanta, yeah.
- Oh yeah yeah yeah.
- You know, it's just-
- Just go.
- Here's why. One girl in LA who like
thinks your pretty and
thinks your cool retweets it,
happens to be the fucking niece of fucking
Rihanna's hairdresser,
and they're sitting right,
people don't get it.
- Yeah, you never know.
- That shit is-
- You can't understand
how real that is, guys.
And then all of a sudden
that hairdresser plays it
Rihanna's like what is that?
You know, Rihanna's in the mood.
She's in the mood to put
somebody on for no reason
other than she can.
And she does what fucking Kylie Jenner did
with PnB Rock and Lip Syncs. One hook,
and your fucking life's over over night.
Figures times four thousand.
Plus you never know what
it's gonna come from.
You've got the Megan Mellon music stuff,
and then you've got a
42 year old business man
who's got an audience that
fucking fucks with him
that fucking, like it helps you too.
The amount of people who tell me
my cosign has been
bigger for them than like
real fucking shit
you know, like stuff
they were looking for?
- That's real good.
- Yeah. Chance and hard work.
- Right? Like an Esports
on Twitch fucks with you
and starts playing in the
background happens to be
ninja, you know?
- Are you big on Twitch?
- I'm about to be.
We built a huge Twitch studio.
- You did? Holy shit.
- My office.
- That's awesome.
- You know what I mean?
You never know, right?
- Yeah. What do you see today,
two years from now we'll be
like there's the fucking-
- Doesn't matter two years from now.
Instagram and Twitch
today, two years from now
who the fuck knows, right?
Blockchain may do this, AI may do that,
voice may do this, here's what's up.
You're one song away.
I got one for you.
You should- there's a
Netflix documentary called
The Toys We Grew Up With.
- [Man] Yeah.
- You've watched it?
- [Man] I haven't watched the whole thing-
- But you've seen it?
- [Man] Seen parts of it, yeah.
- You should find out who produces it,
email them, and tell
them to use Figures in it
because it's all about action figures.
Like got it?
Got it?
Just call, hit, be like
listen, we have this incredible
artist, we have an incredible
song that went viral for her,
it's called Figures and
we love action figures,
do you want to use it in the
background of like season 2?
All of a sudden you've got
people listening to it,
and they're just like,
you know who's done
this up, Good Charlotte.
Good Charlotte broke because of Madden.
- Damn.
- So like how do you get
your songs just heard?
- The Toys We Grew Up With. Good.
Cool, man.
Thank you.
That's fucking cool.
How far is the studio?
- Close.
- [Man] 30th and (indistinguishable)
- Alright. Is Twitch there?
- Twitch-
- No, not Twitch, Jesus Christ,
no, no, no, no.
- Tierra?
- No.
- Tab? FIFA?
- No, sorry, I just had a brain fart.
I'm gonna be completely honest.
I thought that there was
somebody there that was playing,
that's been playing-
- Tyler, my admin, love loves FIFA.
Like loves it.
Yeah, if you start playing Twitch on FIFA,
this is how my mind works.
You're doing that, it gets shared,
some fucking soccer player
who plays in fucking Europe
who's got 8 million fans,
like who's this pretty girl
playing fucking FIFA, DM's
you, trying to like creep.
You're all business, you're
like cool, come play with me.
Now it's fucking-
(Jess laughs)
18 million fucking people,
this is why, this is how my brain works.
This is how I think differently.
They're like cool, you got
Europe from the fucking label?
Cool, my man the fucking soccer
player has got 22 million
people on fucking Instagram
comes through when he's in LA
during the off season
of the European league
after the World Cup, plays
fucking FIFA with her,
takes the photo, and it's game over.
You got all Europe.
- Yeah.
- Got it?
- That's dope, man.
- [Man] You can connect,
too, because Jose Aldo
follows you on Instagram-
- I would fucking DM the fuck outta him.
Be like yo,
- Because he would be down.
Jose DM, we like, yeah.
- I'm sure he does.
DM and be like yo,
let's fucking play FIFA,
let's play Twitch because people freak,
that's my strategy, like
Draymond Green is done with the
NBA finals, he's coming to
the office, we're gonna play
NBA Jams. I'm gonna play FIFA
in the sport that they do
on Twitch old school, cuz
I don't play the new stuff,
so like fucking double
dribble from Nintendo.
Yeah.
(guys laugh)
- [Man] NBA Jams, man.
- Uh-huh.
I played it today, but
it's a new controller,
I'm like oh, fuck.
(Jess laughs)
- [Man] That's crazy.
- That's cool, man.
- Play Tony Hawk's fucking
skateboarding with Tony Hawk.
- [Man] That'd be great, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's awesome.
- You have so much going for you.
You just need to fucking strike.
- Yeah.
- One song away.
I believe that.
I mean you guys wait, like,
I'm always very careful
with my overly aggressive
one song away, because
I have empathy like,
some people like, you know,
the way they think of like,
I feel like I'm an
artist as a business man,
so I get like somebody who
carefully curates 15 songs.
In their head, it makes
this perfect fucking story.
I just know that 99.9%
of the time it doesn't,
for the end user, it
does when they tell them
what it was about.
- [Man] Give it context.
- Yeah, if it can just live on its own-
- You hear an album and you're like
oh, it's a great album.
Then she goes on fucking
BET or fucking like
a documentary or like
fucking on the internet
and was like, yo this-
so the whole part of this album was like
what I was going through during this week,
and you're like oh!
But like, not really.
You see where I'm going?
It's like Monday morning
quarterbacking where
there's like, if you like
just put out like songs,
like you're one song away.
I will never waiver from this
because I know I'm right.
It's what the internet's about.
In the same way that you
should have made music videos
in 1984 to 1987, and
a lot of people didn't
because they thought it
was giving away free music
and it was taking away from sales,
I think you should make as many songs
as you got in your heart
for Spotify and Apple Music
in as many different ways
as possible. The end.
- [Man] It's what they want, too.
- People want music.
- [Man] They do.
- We were trying to play the game of like,
not play the game, but
also watch legends on how
Adele was able to build such
demand but still not like-
- Listen, Adele did that a
hundred thousand years ago.
Would Adele do that in 2018?
- [Man] You know what the
reality, he's talking to
David Jacobson (indistinguishable)
because from 19 to 21 for three years,
she did every fucking
thing humanly possible
to get in front of people's eyes,
and she finally got the
one record that was it-
- The end.
- Then she was done.
But she did everything,
everything to get to that place.
So we still,
we need to get to that place.
- 100%. People try to get
fancy before they're fancy.
(Jess laughs)
- Too precious.
- Fancy before you're fancy.
- I have a question for you, and I might
(indistinguishable)
A little bit of an issue
that Jessie comes with her
is micromanagement.
- Yep.
- What's,
for Jessie to break out of that, to macro,
what do you think- what advice-
- If she trusts you,
based on that question,
she's gotta let you do
one thing that looks like
micromanage, and then she's
gotta see it's not that scary.
- I'm doing that, though, no?
I just got like your,
this was, Brandon was
trying to press on me
for a long time.
I know I got a ways to go.
I know I got a ways to go-
- It's hard, by the way,
it's also you.
Like it's a lot easier
to trust when you're not
the product.
It's you.
- Right, right, yeah.
- So it's harder, I get it.
Like I don't fucking let my,
like it's hard.
I do,
like I don't even edit this.
This whole vlog, I don't even look at it.
- Really?
Cool.
- But when you're the product,
it's harder than anything else,
but yeah, I mean like you-
depending on what you're
actually talking about,
scale only comes when you let go,
and when you realize the
audience is the judge, not you.
As long as you don't
feel horrible about it.
As long as they're not telling you like
yo, you need to put on a
clown suit and go perform
at this Bar Mitzvah and
sing Barbara Streisand.
- See, I told you I didn't
want to fucking do that.
(guys laugh)
- Make music with people.
You know why I-
let me give you a real curve ball.
You're going to think
it's cool when you're old.
Like when you're
your grandkids are gonna think it's cool.
Like think about this, we
don't know what's gonna happen.
Like do it while you can do it.
Like imagine, I'm gonna
make it real simple.
Let's play it the other
way, not about you,
about somebody else.
Imagine people that could
have done collabs with Madonna
and didn't.
- Don't have that story to tell now.
- Right?
You know that guy,
you know that fucking Karees
One's thinking right now,
that he said no, that like,
instead of going to the
studio and doing that one song
with Biggie when Biggie was on the way up,
he decided to just stay at home.
- Shit, that sucks.
- Right?
- It's true, man.
- It's very true.
- Don't be fancy before you're fancy.
- Yeah.
- Don't be fancy
- I really like that.
- Before you're fancy.
That's exactly right.
Got it?
- Yeah, man.
- That's what's up.
Like, that's why I keep meeting,
like people are always
like why are you meeting
with like all these people?
You should be meeting with other people.
You don't have that much time,
I'm like don't be fancy
until you're fancy.
You know?
Like I go from like
the meeting range I go from-
- Yeah, what's your goal?
Where will you turn in like five years?
- I wanna,
I have come to realize in
the last three or four years,
like everything I thought
was true is probably true,
which is like
I'm a, I'm playing a
fundamentally different game
than almost everybody, and like
my goals breakdown in things.
One, I want to have no
regrets when I'm old.
Big.
Right?
So like I'm squeezing everything, right?
Number two,
I want to have the most
people show up to a funeral
of all time.
- [Jess] Nice.
Have that many people feel connected-
- There's a very important
thing about funerals.
It takes a lot for somebody
to not do their normal day,
or what they're supposed to be up to,
and stop and travel to somebody's funeral.
I'm trying to figure out,
I want my grandkids to
just cry and be like,
and by then I tend to-
like I honestly think I'm gonna be famous,
like real famous,
like honestly,
and I still think-
- [Man] You think or you don't think?
- I do.
- [Man] You think, yeah.
- I think I'll be real, real famous.
I still think I'll have
more people at my funeral
than anybody thinks.
- [Man] Right.
- Because there's a reason
I'm becoming famous,
and it's not because I can
sing, or because I'm pretty,
or because I'm good at basketball,
the only reason people fuck with me
is because I'm bringing
them value mentally.
You know? Like, it's a
totally different rea-
you have to understand the reas-
it's the reason musicians are so big.
The escape is in that music
does for them is all time.
It does it for me.
The reason I got real
hyped this weekend was cuz
I just listed to fucking Tee Grizzley,
I remember like over and over,
like 400 thousand, like I listened to it
for 11 hours in the last four days.
11 hours.
- [Man] Crazy.
- Cuz that's how I get.
Because Tee Grizzley is gonna
win because of the opening
line of that song, which is like,
yeah, I still think $50 is a lot of money.
- [Jess] Yeah, man, real shit.
- All three of you will
regret if you don't
squeeze the fuck out of this
for the rest of your life
if you don't pop.
- That's serious.
- That's super real.
Which is why like every
collab, every song,
you'll just regret it. I
don't know what to tell you.
- Yeah.
- You will. I know.
You're too far.
You're too far along.
It's too special, it's
too obvious. You know.
There's nobody sitting
here that doesn't know
she's a star. I just know
millions of stars never made it.
I believe that.
- Yeah.
- I fucking believe that.
- When did your brain switch
over to this kind of mentality,
to this got something,
when you like,
I don't know, cuz every
teenager goes through it,
when they're kind of like-
- So I, so that is definitely,
so here's what happened
with me as a teenager
that's played out here, I'll
answer your question better.
There are very few teenagers
that ever live their life
the way I did, which is
I couldn't hear anybody.
Man, I can't tell you,
I can't tell you this,
I didn't hear anybody.
Meaning
think about high school, like a kid,
everybody's opinions matters too much,
I just valued nobody's opinion but mine.
I was in my own head.
And now like weird, like
I'm super social and
not the awkward, like,
super outwardly normal, like
I'm unbelievably socially,
like everybody liked me,
I just couldn't hear you.
- Do you think that's
something innate in you
or is that something
your parents gave you?
- I think both.
- How did your parents give you that?
- I think my mom brainwashed
me that I was the best.
(Jess laughs)
And that's, so I was like,
yeah I don't care, like-
- [Man] What'd she say?
- Like yeah, like I'm not gonna-
when people are like "you
gotta drink this to be cool,"
I'm like I don't value
those people enough,
but I love you.
And I see that you're
cool, and you're pretty,
and you're cool, and
you're the most popular,
but like fuck you. I'm
not fucking drinking beer
if I don't want to drink beer.
My core best friends in college,
like these are my homies,
their only goal in life
was to get me to take
one hit from one blunt
one time in four years,
and I didn't do it.
- [Jess] Are you still friends with them?
- Yeah.
That was like their,
and you think about the silliness in that,
like you know what I mean?
I just didn't want to.
That was it.
Like lines in the-
so to answer you,
what happened, it happened,
God I don't even know
when it happened or how it happened,
but for some reason, I just
never let peer pressure
come in in any shape, form,
I was doing such crazy shit.
I was like in high school going to like
the dollar store, buying
shit, and selling it,
like I'd do baseball
cards shows in the mall,
and all my friends are like,
when you're a sophomore in high school,
you're like trying to do it,
you know? Like, and I'm
like sitting in the mall,
like trying to sell baseball cards,
and like I know my friends that were like,
even girls that kind of
liked me in high school
were kind of like
why are you, don't do that.
You know?
And I was like fuck you. I'm doing me.
And I've always been that way.
And I think now it's playing out where
what's really manifested
is like that's the game.
The game is like to do everything
for you,
for them.
You gotta, like I always
think about being selfish
to be selfless.
I think I'm so selfish is my own shit,
but then it allows me,
that's why I can give so
much because I'm not looking,
I'm not looking for anybody
to give me validation.
I'm a very validated,
that means I've already
moved on to the next part.
I feel like I'm old.
Does that make sense? I feel like I'm 90.
Like you know how like 90
year olds don't give a fuck
no more?
Like that's,
you know? Like,
they're like I'm old,
what are you gonna say?
Fuck you.
- What's the best piece of
advice that you've ever gotten?
- What's that?
- What's the best piece of
advice that you ever got?
If you had to summarize
it into one sentence.
- Uh, it wasn't a single piece of advice,
it was a process that
my dad put me through
when I was 14 to 16 that said-
- Word is bond.
- My dad taught me word is bond.
- [Jess] Dope.
I want to know about pride,
because I have so many (indistinguishable)
that I wanna do, but I
remember getting advice when
I was in this youth program in Toronto,
and I was like I wanna give
back, I wanna give back,
and I was trying to do
music and do sessions
and do interviews, and one of the mentors,
Ricky, he was like
honestly Jess, you have to-
which resonates with
what you said earlier,
you got to be selfish to be selfless,
- Go deep, become huge in
music, you do everything you do-
honestly, that's exactly right.
I want to capture everyone's
attention on Earth
so that I can make an impact.
Like I know I'm right.
I want legacy.
Honestly, Jess, just to answer you,
I want legacy, I want nothing else, man.
Honestly, I don't want to make more money.
Other than if I make enough
money to buy the Jets
it's gonna inspire everybody,
because I'm gonna have
30 years of content saying
I'm gonna do it and then
I do it and people are
gonna be like holy shit,
it's gonna something crazy.
Other than that, and knowing
that I'll get a movie
about me, and like,
you know,
the boy that bought the Jets,
but other than that,
it's funny, I was in my house out east,
and I was looking at the
sweater that my mom knitted me,
because I couldn't even
afford a Jets jersey,
I was looking at it, I was like
I'm gonna fucking- just
had a moment to myself
like I'm gonna fucking do this.
I gonna fucking do it.
But that's more about the chase.
You know that's kind of
like, if I was being honest,
it's more like I'm gonna win 11 Grammy's.
That's more about just like doing,
like that's more of a, yeah, it's a game.
But for real for real, the funeral.
You know?
The funeral.
That means you won.
Do you know how many people
make $48 million and have
eight people at their fucking funeral?
- Yeah.
- I want people like,
I want people that don't
even know why they're at
my funeral, they're like,
I want people like
mingling with each other
and be like why are you here,
and like my grandma made
me come because in 2018
she watched a video
and she left my grandpa
who was abusing her and
she built a business,
you know what I mean? Real shit.
- Real shit.
And that's what I get in DM's all day.
Real.
My DM's are real shit, like
heavy shit.
But like the reason I think
I'm gravitating towards music
is I recognize for me to
pull off all my ambitions
I need the biggest pillars in our culture,
in our lives, and music is one of those.
- What's another one?
- Sports.
- And?
- Um, I actually think
that fashion is one,
but that doesn't come natural to me.
These are cultural pillars, you know?
Then there's things like
religion, things of that nature,
but that's almost like a different thing,
but like music and sports are
food.
Food.
- If you, if I was to say like
what do you think would
be an (indistinguishable),
because that's one of my
goals, (indistinguishable)
one of my goals is like legacy.
I want to die a legend,
I want to be able to buy
my dad a farm, I have a
few Grammy's on my shelf,
I want to get 12 things and
name them after my mother,
and I want to help a million people.
From like years ago has been officially
what I want to do.
- You can really do that.
You're one song away from that.
Everything you just said
you're one song away from.
I'm being dead fucking serious with you.
No no, stick with me,
everything you just said,
like you can add things later,
but everything you just rattled off,
the fucking farm, the
Grammy's, the million people,
you're one song away.
Logic's fucking song reached
more than a million people.
If you don't think that
fucking Hotline song
impacted a million people,
easy million.
Millions.
One song away.
That's what's up. Like honestly,
I wish, probably in a lot
of ways subconsciously
and consciously, that I could sing or rap,
because like the way I communicate,
I can make viral videos,
but fucking I'd have
seven
did you see what Tee Grizzley
and Tierra said about
when I was, oh, you're not in the text,
did you see what they said?
I'm like texting them lyrics,
this is just like random shit
that I would make videos about,
- They said you sounded like Drake?
- Yeah. And it was funny,
I was sitting there and I was like
that makes so much sense
that they think that.
Cuz like, it's all the same shit.
- You did sound like Drake.
He was coming up with lyrics,
trying to inspire them,
just spinning his own lyric,
you did sound like Drake.
(guys laugh)
- I couldn't make that connection.
I listen to Drake, I didn't
make that connection.
But like I know that
it's all the same shit.
Back to the fine line.
You're one song away from
everything you just said.
Like I think I posted on
Instagram, did I post it yet?
The I'm- we didn't make that post yet,
I tweeted it, but we don't have the
I'm gonna shove positivity
down your throat,
nobody made it yet?
- I'm gonna shove
positivity down your throat?
- I'm literally tweeted yesterday,
I'm like I'm gonna shove
positivity down your
collective throats, like
for the rest of the time,
for my life, period, end of story,
cuz it's the truth.
Look how blessed we are.
Fuck are we doing here?
- Real shit.
How much your fucking denim jacket cost?
You know, that's more than
my family made in two months,
my fucking dinner bills,
I had dinner with my
parents the other night, I had dinner with
my parents like a month
ago, which is rare, right?
Just the four of us.
The dinner bill was more than our rent
for the first two years
we lived in America.
Fuck are we doing here?
Nobody is America should
complain about nothing.
- What do your folks do?
Are they retired now?
- No, my dad, we had a
family liquor business,
that's where I started,
and he still goes and
opens up the store every
day, causing ruckus,
and my mom was always stay at home.
She's just being a grandma and fucking
she fucking worked her face off, man,
like no help, three kids, like fucking,
we didn't do shit.
She did laundry, clean, like old school,
like fuck she was a maid.
- Albanian?
- What's that?
- Bella Russia.
- My family was close to that.
- You know?
Lack of entitlement.
- Uphill's normal.
- And what's fucked up
is you can get caught,
like all these crazy
things happening for you
you lose sight.
You know?
- How do you stay, how do you stay,
like I try to keep lists and shit and like
reminders on my phone
screen of like, humbleness-
- I'm running it.
- Consistently?
- Yeah.
- You never like need a
physical title or list
to bring you back?
- Not me, but everyone's different, right?
Everyone learns different, everybody,
you know, I definitely-
it's funny, back to
this Tee Grizzley song,
I'm not kidding, it was
interesting how much it
motivated, I was like okay wait a minute,
this is good.
It's cool to see an outside
source bring me some value.
Like, I'm in my own shit.
I just can't not know.
My perspective's too
off the fucking chart.
My perspective's a 30 on the 10 scale.
- You meditate?
- Every second of my life, I think.
Got it? It's the same
answer to the last question.
I don't need a tactical
thing to ground me,
I'm grounded.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean? It is.
You know what I mean? Like,
the same way that I breathe
oxygen, I fucking know it's great.
And I'm thankful and grateful as fuck,
and I know I'm the best,
and I know, I mean, shit.
- Well that's it, dude. Congrats.
- Thank you so much for your time, man.
Appreciate it.
(guitar music)
♪ Figures ♪
♪ I gave you ride or die
and you gave me game ♪